In this video, I'll show you how to install R
and RStudio. To get started you want to go to
cran.rstudio.com. And then you'll click on the link to download
R for Windows. If you never installed the R programming language
before, then click on this first link. Since it's your
first time downloading it. Now depending on your version of Windows,
you might need to see the frequently asked questions. I'm
set for my computer, so I'm going to go ahead and download
R for Windows. I get a warning message and
I want to keep the file. Now this might take
some time to download, so just be patient. Then
you want to open the file, and then run the program.
A set up wizard should appear and now you
just want to walk through all the steps. I'll set
my language, and then I'll just continue installing by
hitting next. I'm just going to accept the defaults here and
then install it to R. I'll leave these as is,
so that way a desktop icon will be created. And
it's going along. Great. Now I'm finished with my setup.
So that was just part one of the installation process.
That just gave us the programming language R. Now we
need to go and install RStudio. RStudio is a graphical
user interface for programming in R. It's basically a point
and click system that let's us work with data really easily.
So first let's just go to download now to get RStudio.
We're going to get RStudio for our desktop. So just click this first
button. Now there's going to be a lot of links here, and you
really just want this first link. It's going to be the version of
RStudio that's recommended for your computer, and for your operating system.
Notice how this one's for Windows XP, Vista, Windows 7, or Windows
8, so I'll click on that, and then I'll keep the file.
And you can see it downloading in the bottom left corner, here.
It looks like it's ready, so I'm going to
open this up. I'll then install RStudio into this path.
And create a Start Menu folder as well. Great. I'm done. And this is
what RStudio looks like. Now yours might
look slightly different than mine and that might
be because the file's open. So if I go to File > New File
> R Script this opens a basic R script which allows me to start programming in R.